i'm sorry i was looking at dr mike's
legs and i'm like he kind of thick
oh what do you think about that
[Music]
welcome to another episode of responding
to your comments you might be wondering
where am i so am i what happened to the
youtube space
this makes me feel good i'm gonna cover
the whole outside of my house in this
material
chill i'm gonna be a star movie stuff
yeah
[Music]
all right i said in my 50 facts video
that i have a problem with my fat thighs
and it's hard to find good fitting pants
because of this problem and then when i
do my video with my nephews who i was so
excited for you to see them the only
thing you guys could talk about were my
fat thighs i feel like i should just do
a video where it's just my thighs for
like 38 minutes people with fat dies
need love too
lieutenant salamander slamander is it
safe to wear seven watches on one arm
you betcha okarutto can you talk about
forms of birth controls and their side
effects and especially what the best
protection is for teens i feel like many
schools including mine are still not
teaching enough about these kinds of
stuff generally the way that i talk
about it with my patients is on an
individual level what is it that they're
looking to do what are they looking to
prevent what risks are they taking that
i should be thinking about in the back
of my head when i make a recommendation
and then i print out a little paper that
has
some of the options for birth controls
as well as the percentages of how well
they work with perfect use and then
usual use because they're not the same
thing i ask them to read it and then
come back so we can have a discussion
about what they read which one's their
favorite what they think they want to do
each person has their own needs each
person has their own medical conditions
each person's taking their own different
set of medications and supplements i
can't just give a generalized best type
of birth control recommendation because
it matters comfort vanessa mathwasi
kabungo dr mike what are your views
regarding human cloning do you support
it if yes would you want to get cloned
human clothing clothing cloning scares
me because i've watched a lot of sci-fi
movies now this is not a medical opinion
this is not a scientific opinion i mean
could you imagine if there was another
dr mike right here yeah what's the
problem bruh
[Music]
that's why valerie tucker do you think
high school students are chronically
sleep deprived taking into account when
we go to sleep and when we have to be up
for school i think the answer to that is
yes and i think schools have already
started to take notice of this by making
classes start later when you're in your
teenage years it's natural that you're
going to go to sleep a little bit later
because you want to be rebellious and
you want to be cool you want to play
overwatch get on masters level like
myself when you have to wake up at 5 6
a.m and you're going to sleep at
midnight that's not enough time for you
to recover to reset your brain to get
your hormones going to rest your muscles
it's just not enough so what i recommend
to high school students is eight to ten
hours of sleep this is more than when
you become an adult and i say aim for
seven to nine leah dr mike
doc mike go see your doctor
[Music]
yes i often say that you should go see
your doctor because if you're going to
ask me about a specific specific problem
i can give you a general answer about
what the problem could be
what you should be on the lookout for
what are scary symptoms this and that
but i can't give you individual advice
and most of the time the best advice i
can give you is to go see your doctor
because that's what my job in this
channel is is to educate you to make
better decisions to feel comfortable to
speak with your doctor to see that we're
humans too we make mistakes we sometimes
say we don't know we have fun we laugh
we have dogs we have furry walls
maggie durgans if a patient has painted
nails how do you check them properly i
ask them to take the nail polish off or
i ask them to come in the following time
with no nail polish on it's obviously
not ideal and it's also
not of utmost importance if you have for
example a very healthy patient that
otherwise has no issues vanna how can
somebody become a doctor if they're not
good at science or math if you have a
natural curiosity there's always a way
to get good at it and i don't even know
specifically why you're talking about
math unless you're practicing anesthesia
or something very specific limited math
skills are needed to be a good doctor
evelina kaelin is it true that women
have a higher pain tolerance than men i
don't know if i've ever heard that from
a research standpoint i can see why
someone would say that because women
deliver babies and that is obviously a
very painful experience that's a good
question maybe i'll do a video on that
gory baker i keep eating chips panties
pringles am i dying
that's carbs that you don't need that's
a lot of salt you don't need you're
gonna get all puffy and weird don't do
it don't do it don't do it lena farr
zolari
merch where's the merch oh man i've been
saying that for the longest time i
promise i want to make merch i'm more
looking to figure out the trademark
situation so as soon as that gets
figured out i promise you're gonna have
merch i'm gonna be wearing it on the
channel cameron harvey are fart needles
a real thing
i'm googling it someone wrote getting
the fart needles i'm watching
are you this the third needles again dad
never mind what i'm getting i have no
idea what fart needles are but please
describe to me in in the comment section
what the heck a fart needle is asia
thomas cosquaya hi dr mike is the sauna
good for our health oh i feel like we
should get rhonda patrick on the show
cause she's a big sauna supporter i'll
tell you this in the home where i grew
up in staten island my dad has a sauna
we use it all the time when i go to the
gym i use the sauna i do think there are
health benefits obviously that's
something that's very very difficult to
study because it's difficult to do in a
controlled randomized environment
correlation studies have shown some
pretty impressive health benefits to
those when you compare those who use
saunas to those who don't and you see
that effect go up based on how often
they use the saunas so it's dose
dependent which shows that it probably
has something to do with the sauna gets
me really excited about it because i
love saunas i think it's really relaxing
just don't fall for all of that it helps
you release toxins no you don't release
toxins in a sauna you sweat and that
gives your cardiovascular system a
stress and like i said before those
short-term stresses are really good for
your body but has nothing to do about
releasing toxins damari yarsonia dr mike
do doctors listen to music while
performing surgery yeah they do they
rock out all the time i've been with
doctors that listen to anything from
kenny g
jazz to
eminem people vibe in the operating room
we have a good time it's all about
maintaining you know a good
morale amongst both the doctor and the
other health professionals that are in
the room at the same time alyssa asado
does your heart really stop every time a
person sneezes
no also your heart isn't beating like
this
a person's heart generally beats
anywhere from 60 to 100 beats per minute
at rest so if they're beating 60 beats
per minute that's one beat every second
right so if you sneeze i chew
how would it stop beating you mean he'll
skip a beat no core
corno
dr mike and ken jong need a
collaboration now now i know we need
this dr ken jung please come to thy
channel let's talk medicine and have a
laugh because i've heard a very wise
person once say
laughter
can be medicine i usually get all my
questions and comments from the youtube
videos but i wanted to get some from
twitter this time by the way if you're
not following me you should my username
is realdoctormike on twitter let's
tackle some of these twitter questions
slowtown swift13 how do you manage to
film videos edit upload them and work as
a doctor what are your tips on time
management love your vids thank you so
much i don't edit my videos my man dino
when's sitting behind the camera edits
the videos and he's very good at it i
think part of the success of the youtube
channel is my ability to give
information in an easy to understand
relatable way and then the other part of
it is dan's rockstar editing so without
him this channel doesn't exist how do i
manage my time honestly i just keep
going and involve myself in all these
activities that i genuinely love and am
passionate about and when i do that it
doesn't feel like i'm forcing myself to
do anything i just do it i get so much
positivity and feedback from you guys
from the love that i have for what i do
and as a result of that i stay very
motivated i recommend you find what you
love to do as well kirsten parker what
do you think will be a bigger health
issue among gen z due to iphone usage
neck pain or bad vision the posture of
walking and talking on your iphone is
really bad for your spine and people who
are walking and texting and
falling into those basement shafts or
walking into traffic oh my god it's so
scary for me please if you're gonna use
your phone have a seat use it and then
live your life it's so much better to
limit your screen time and enjoy the
world around you then constantly to be
buried inside here emma herder uh when
are you starting a podcast i know and i
saw the person that tweeted at me i
don't know if it was you emma that said
we got 20 000 likes on that podcast
comment from the video i have looked
into starting a podcast i've even worked
with a company in doing this we threw
around some ideas but the amount of time
that needs to be dedicated to a podcast
i feel like isn't worth the trade-off
just yet because if i want to do let's
say a podcast format where i have guests
on or i give you some sort of long-form
content we could just do it right here
on youtube right now i'm kind of holding
off on the podcast situation i hope you
understand please tell my mom that
homeopathic medicine is bogus raul's mom
homeopathic it shouldn't be called
medicine homeopathy is bogus forget
about it i love answering your guys
questions and i actually put together a
playlist of my favorite responding to
comments videos so click it
and stay happy and healthy
[Music]